[Music]
people have often wondered what it would
take to force sport to really punish a
pariah nation
well now we know a full-blown invasion
and the slaughter of innocent people in
ukraine has forced sport to rewrite the
rules
[Music]
this is now
so serious that sport it cannot sit the
dance out and whether it's fans or the
players themselves the strength of
feeling is self-evident
[Applause]
so which sports have banned russia from
competing
the football authorities have now
suspended russia from all uefa and fifa
competitions and that is a big step
considering that just four years ago
russia hosted the fifa world cup
they won't be in this year's tournament
in qatar and there will be no russian
team in the women's euros that are going
to be held here in england this summer
the organizers of the olympic games who
themselves have a pretty weird and
complicated relationship with russia
have said that any athletes from russia
or from belarus should not be competing
rugby union has also acted they've
suspended russia and belarus
and even vladimir putin's favorite
sports
he was an honorary president of the
international judo federation
but not anymore para olympian angie
malone lit the flame for the winter
paralympics in beijing a committee
initially decided that athletes from
russia and belarus would be allowed to
compete as neutrals
but in a dramatic u-turn just 24 hours
before the start of the games the
outrage was impossible to ignore
the russian and belarusian paralympians
were banned because of the invasion in
ukraine so what difference will all this
actually make well money is one of the
most obvious because the finances of
mega rich oligarchs are wrapped up in so
many sporting clubs and those clubs have
a dilemma do they side with morals or
the money and in this appalling conflict
it seems there is only one choice that
is acceptable
[Music]
you